[Música]
enigmáticos insólitos extravagantes son
los palacios de todos los superlativos
[Música]
viviendas graciosas obras de arte
surgidas de la imaginación sin límites
de sus creadores genios incomprendidos
tal como El ladrón en otheriff donde se
erige el Palacio ideal de ferdinancheval
190.000 visitantes tratan de interpretar
su misterio cada año
hay una mezcla un conjunto de elementos
completamente
eclécticos pero que funcionan
perfectamente juntos
mi arquitecto ni escultor ferdina
ancheval era un Modesto cartero del
siglo XIX cada noche después de su
recorrido acarreaba bloques de piedra y
herejía poco a poco su Palacio ideal le
tomó 33 años realizar una obra en
clasificable Aquí hay una serie de
columnas monumentales con una cabeza de
Centauro cuatro pequeñas columnas de
bajo que lo sostienen todo y los
restauradores del palacio siempre nos
dicen no sabemos cómo se sostiene todo
esto desafía las leyes de la gravedad un
Enigma arquitectónico poblado de
animales y personajes mitológicos
evocación de templos de oriente un viaje
soñado inspirado en los diarios
ilustrados de la época o en las postales
que el cartero chaval repartía
la galería Es la maravilla de las
Maravillas
está poblada de esculturas de una
ornamentación extraordinaria aquí aves
conchas usadas al revés para trabajar la
huella
la obra primero suscitó urlas estando
vivo su Creador antes de encontrar un
eco más adelante en los surrealistas y
artistas como Picasso símbolo del arte
inocente el Palacio interroga y aún
inspira este autor de historietas no se
aburre de fijarse hasta en los más
mínimos detalles
[Música]
dibujarlo también es una forma de
entenderlo y sentir el vértigo que él
debía sentir uno se pierde en él no se
entiende todo pero literalmente nos
transporta es un Enigma muy poético
el cartero chival quería dejar una
huella su misterioso Palacio hoy en día
está clasificado como monumento
histórico otro lugar otro Enigma de
piedra en medio de los campos de Mayén
Este es un palacio museo protegido por
un dragón y personajes que poblaron la
infancia del artista Roberta tan su obra
bocadora fascina a 40.000 visitantes al
año
es una chimenea imaginamos salir el humo
tenemos el primer elemento el fuego
es fabuloso Yo no esperaba ver tantas
cosas tantos elementos tantas riquezas
en este pequeño lugar
tiene la impresión de entender su
proceso no totalmente hay que trabajar
trabajar porque hay muchas señales
muchas cosas es complejo
para tratar de entender esta mirada de
artista hay que conocer a Roberto tan
estudiante de Bellas Artes en París
también fue pintor de edificios
carpintero y ceramista una autodidacta
desconcertante que manejaba el buril con
la misma desenvoltura que el pincel y la
filosofía
[Música]
su casa integrada al museo quedó intacta
desde su muerte en 1983
del taller de pintura al baño el artista
moldeó hasta el más mínimo detalle
no había distinción entre su mirada de
artista y su vida cotidiana se llamaba
el artesano porque para él no había
diferencia
y podía tomar esas riquezas
artesanos locos arquitectos de casas
inhabitables Había algo en estos
artistas que no andaba bien De ninguna
manera en el creador del palacio burbuja
en la costa azul esta curiosidad
arquitectónica con diseño redondo es en
efecto una casa Esta es la entrada
la locura por lo redondo es de antilovac
una arquitecto finlandés vanguardista
que se instaló en la costa azul en los
años 70 diseñó los planos del palacio
burbujas y le Vendió la casa a
piercardín el modista hizo de él su
fuente de inspiración
es como un cuerpo humano los corredores
son arterias
las joyas son las venas hay un cerebro
un corazón actualmente el Palacio
burbujas ya no está habitado ya en
Pascal ges está encargado de hacer vivir
el lugar 2000 metros cuadrados o más
bien redondos de superficie habitable y
por todas partes fabulosas aberturas de
luz
Era el principio de la casa esta
arquitectura orgánica con esta abertura
esta piscina de desbordamiento una de
las primeras piscinas de desbordamiento
de la costa azul
al desviarse de los corredores hay 12
suites alcobas con mobiliario
perfectamente adaptado tenemos en toda
la Suite una cama redonda con sanitarios
redondos el baño la tina redonda
todo es redondo
información para los aficionados desde
la muerte de Pierre cardán el Palacio
burbuja está en venta se estima que
cuesta 400 millones de euros lo que la
hace una de las propiedades más costosas
del mundo pero ante todo un palacio de
artista inestimable